[Music]
i am a writer
writing books is my profession but it's
more than that of course it is also my
great lifelong love and fascination
and i don't expect that that's ever
going to change but
that said
something kind of peculiar has happened
recently in my life
and in my career which has caused me to
have to sort of recalibrate my whole
relationship with this work and the
peculiar thing
is that i recently wrote this book this
memoir called eat pray love
which decidedly unlike any of my
previous books
went out in the world for some reason
and became this big mega sensation
international bestseller thing the
result of which
is that everywhere i go now people treat
me like i'm doomed
um seriously doomed doomed like they
come up to me now like all worried and
they say aren't you afraid aren't you
afraid you're never going to be able to
top that
aren't you afraid you're going to keep
writing for your whole life and you're
never again going to create a book that
anybody in the world cares about at all
ever
again
so that's reassuring you know
but it would be worse except for that i
happen to remember that over 20 years
ago when i first started telling people
when i was a teenager that i wanted to
be a writer i was met with this same
kind of sort of fear-based reaction and
people would say aren't you afraid
you're never going to have any success
aren't you afraid the humiliation of
rejection will kill you aren't you
afraid that you're going to work your
whole life at this craft and nothing's
ever going to come of it and you're
going to die on a scrap heap of broken
dreams with your mouth
filled with bitter ash of failure
like that you know and um
the answer
short answer to all those questions is
yes um yes i'm afraid of all those
things and i always have been and i'm
afraid of many many more things besides
that you know people can't even guess at
like um seaweed and and other things
that are scary but when it comes to
writing um the the thing that i've been
sort of thinking about lately and
wondering about lately is why you know
is it rational is it logical that um
anybody should be expected to be afraid
of the work that they feel they were put
on this earth to do you know and what is
it
specifically about creative ventures
that seems to make us really nervous
about each other's mental health in a
way that other careers kind of don't do
you know
like my dad for example was a chemical
engineer and i don't recall once in his
40 years of chemical engineering anybody
asking him if he was afraid to be a
chemical engineer you know it just
didn't come like got chemical
engineering block john you know how's it
going and um
it just didn't come up like that you
know but
to be fair right um chemical engineers
as a group you know haven't really
earned a reputation over the centuries
for being alcoholic manic depressives
and
we writers
you know we kind of do have that
reputation and not not just writers but
creative people across all
genres it seems have this reputation for
being enormously mentally unstable um
and you know all you have to do is look
at the very grim death count in the 20th
century alone of really magnificent
creative minds who died young and often
at their own hands you know and even the
ones who didn't literally commit suicide
seemed to be really undone by their
gifts you know norman mailer just before
he died last interview he said every one
of my books has killed me a little more
an extraordinary statement to make about
your life's work you know but we don't
even blink when we hear somebody say
this because we've heard that kind of
stuff for so long and somehow we've
completely internalized and accepted
collectively this notion that creativity
and suffering are somehow inherently
linked and that artistry in the end will
always ultimately lead to anguish and
the question that i want to ask
everybody here today is um are you guys
all cool with that idea like are you
comfortable with that because um you
look at it even from an inch away and
you know i'm not at all comfortable with
that assumption i think it's odious and
i also think it's dangerous and i don't
want to see it perpetuated into the next
century i think better if we encourage
you know our great creative minds to
live you know um and
uh and i i definitely know that
in in my case in my situation um it
would be very dangerous for me to start
sort of leaking down that dark path of
assumption you know particularly given
the circumstance that i'm in right now
in my career which is you know like
check it out i'm pretty young i'm only
about 40 years old i still have maybe
another four decades of work left in me
and it's exceedingly likely that
anything i write from this point forward
is going to be judged by the world as
the work that came after the freakish
success of my last book right
um
i i should just put it bluntly because
we're all sort of friends here now it's
exceedingly likely that my greatest
success is behind me you know um so
jesus what a thought you know like
that's the kind of thought that could
lead a person to start drinking gin at
nine o'clock in the morning and
you know i don't want to go there you
know i would prefer to keep doing this
work that i love and so the question
becomes how you know and and so it seems
to me upon a lot of reflection that the
way that i have to work now in order to
continue writing is that i have to
create some sort of protective
psychological construct right i have to
sort of find some way to have a safe
distance you know between
me as i am writing and my very natural
anxiety about what the reaction to that
writing is going to be from now on
and and as i've been looking over the
last year for like models for how to do
that i've been sort of looking across
time and i've been trying to find like
other societies to see if they might
have had
better and saner ideas than we have
about how to help
creative people sort of manage the
inherent emotional risks of of
creativity and that search has led me to
ancient greece and ancient rome um so
stay with me because it does circle
around back but um ancient greece in
ancient rome
people did not happen to believe that
creativity came from human beings back
then okay people believed that
creativity was this divine attendance
spirit that came to human beings from
some distant and unknowable source for
distant and unknowable reasons the
greeks famously called these divine
attendant spirits of creativity demons
socrates famously believed that he had a
daemon who spoke wisdom to him from afar
the romans had the same idea but they
called that sort of disembodied creative
spirit a genius um which is great
because the romans did not actually
think that a genius was a particularly
clever individual they believed that a
genius was this sort of magical divine
entity um who was believed to literally
live in the walls of an artist's studio
kind of like dobby the house elf and who
would come out and sort of invisibly
assist the artists with their work and
would shape the outcome of that work so
brilliant there it is right there that
distance that i'm talking about that
psychological construct to protect you
from the results of your work you know
um and everyone knew that this is how it
functioned right so the ancient artist
was protected from certain things like
for example too much narcissism right if
your work was brilliant couldn't take
all the credit for it everybody knew you
had this like disembodied genius who had
helped you if your work bombed not
entirely your fault you know everyone
knew your genius was kind of lame and uh
this is how people thought about
creativity in the west for a really long
time and then the renaissance came and
everything changed and we had this big
idea and the big idea was let's put the
individual human being at the center of
the universe right above all gods and
mysteries and there's no more room for
like mystical creatures who take
dictation from the divine and and it's
the beginning of rational humanism and
people started to believe that
creativity came completely from the self
of the individual and for the first time
in history you start to hear people
referring to this or that artist as
being a genius rather than having a
genius and i got to tell you i think
that was a huge error you know i think
that allowing somebody like one mere
person to believe that he or she is like
the vessel you know like the font and
the essence and the source of all divine
creative unknowable eternal mystery is
just like a smidge too much
responsibility to put on one fragile
human psyche it's like asking somebody
to swallow the sun you know it just
completely warps and distorts egos and
it creates all these unmanageable
expectations about performance and i
think the pressure of that has been
killing off our artists for the last 500
years
and
if this is true and i i think it is true
the question becomes
you know what now you know can we do
this differently uh maybe go back to
some more
ancient understanding about the
relationship between humans and the
creative mystery um
maybe not you know like maybe we can't
just erase 500 years of rational
humanistic thought in one 18-minute
speech
and there's probably people
in this audience who would raise like
really legitimate scientific suspicions
about the notion of basically fairies
who follow
people around like
rubbing fairy juice on their projects
and stuff like i'm not probably going to
bring you all along with me on this um
but the question that i kind of want to
pose is you know why not um why not
think about it this way because it makes
as much sense as anything else i have
ever heard in terms of explaining the
utter maddening capriciousness of the
creative process a process which as
anybody who has ever tried to make
something which is to say as basically
everyone here knows does not always
behave rationally and in fact can
sometimes feel downright paranormal
i had this encounter recently where i
met the extraordinary american poet ruth
stone who's now in her 90s but she's
been a poet her entire life and she told
me that when she was growing up in rural
virginia she would be out working in the
fields and she said she would like feel
and hear a poem coming at her from over
the landscape and she said it was like a
thunderous train of air and it would
come barreling down at her over the
landscape and when she felt it coming
because it would like shake the earth
under her feet she knew that she had
only one thing to do at that point and
that was to in her words run like hell
and she would like run like hell to the
house and she'd be getting chased by
this poem and the whole deal was that
she had to get to a piece of paper and a
pencil fast enough so that when it
thundered through her she could collect
it and grab it on the page and other
times she wouldn't be fast enough so
she'd be like running and running and
running and she wouldn't get to the
house and the poem would like barrel
through her and she would miss it and
she said it would continue on across the
landscape looking as she put it for
another poet
and um and then there were these times
this is the piece i never forgot she
said that there were moments when she
would almost miss it right so she's like
running into the house and she's looking
for the paper and the poem passes
through her and she grabs a pencil just
as it's going through her and then she
said it was like she would reach out
with her other hand and she would catch
it she would catch the poem by its tail
and she would pull it backwards into her
body as she was transcribing on the page
and in these instances the poem would
come up on the page perfect and intact
but backwards from the last word to the
first
so
when i heard that i was like
that's you know that's uncanny that's
exactly what my creative process is like
it's not at all my creative process i'm
not the pipeline you know like i'm a
mule and the way that i have to work is
that i have to get up at the same time
every day and like sweat and labor and
like barrel through it really awkwardly
but even i in my mealishness even i have
brushed up against that thing you know
at times and i would imagine that a lot
of you have to you know like even i have
had
work or ideas come through me from a
source that i honestly cannot identify
and what is that thing and how are we to
relate to it in a way that will not make
us lose our minds but in fact might
actually keep us sane and for me the
best contemporary example that i have of
how to do that
is the musician tom waits who i got to
interview several years ago on a um on a
magazine assignment and we were talking
about this and you know you you know tom
i mean for most of his life he was
pretty much the embodiment of the
tormented contemporary modern artist you
know like trying to control and manage
and dominate these sort of
uncontrollable creative impulses you
know that were totally internalized but
then he got older and he got calmer and
one day he was driving down the freeway
in los angeles he told me and this is
when it all changed for him and um and
he's like speeding along and all of a
sudden he hears this little fragment of
melody you know that comes into his head
as inspiration often comes elusive and
tantalizing and he wants it you know
it's gorgeous and and he longs for it
but he has no way to get it he doesn't
have a piece of paper he doesn't have a
pencil he doesn't have a tape recorder
so he starts to feel all that old
anxiety start to rise in him like i'm
going to lose this thing you know and
i'm going to be haunted by this song
forever and i'm not good enough and i
can't do it and instead of panicking he
just stopped he just stopped that whole
mental process and he did something
completely novel he just looked up at
the sky and he said excuse me can you
not see that i'm driving
do i look like i can write down a song
right now you know if you really want to
exist come back in a more opportune
moment when i can take care of you
otherwise go bother somebody else today
go bother leonard cohen you know
and
and his whole work process changed after
that not the work the work was still
oftentimes as dark as ever you know but
the process and the heavy anxiety around
it was released when he took the genie
the genius out of him where it was
causing nothing but trouble and released
it kind of back where it came from and
realized that this didn't have to be
this internalized tormented thing it
could be this peculiar wondrous bizarre
collaboration kind of conversation
between tom and the strange external
thing that was not quite tom
so when i heard that story it started to
shift a little bit the way that i worked
too and it already saved me once this
idea it saved me when i was in the
middle of writing eat pray love and i
fell into one of those sort of pits of
despair that we all fall into when we're
working on something and it's not coming
and you start to think this is going to
be a disaster this is going to be the
worst book ever not just bad but the
worst book ever written and and i
started to think i should just dump this
project you know um but then i
remembered tom talking to the open air
and i i tried it um so i just lifted my
face up from the manuscript and i
directed my comments to an empty corner
of the room and i i said aloud uh listen
you thing um
you and i both know that if this book
isn't brilliant that is not entirely my
fault right because you can see that i
am putting everything i have into this
you know i don't have any more than this
so if you want it to be better then you
got to show up and do your part of the
deal okay but if you don't do that you
know what the hell with it i'm going to
keep writing anyway because that's my
job and i would please like the record
to reflect today that i showed up for my
part of the job
because
in the end
it's like this okay centuries ago in the
deserts of north africa people used to
gather for these
moonlight dances of sacred dance and
music that would go on for hours and
hours until dawn and they were always
magnificent because the dancers were
professionals and they were terrific
right but every once in a while very
rarely something would happen and one of
these performers would actually become
transcendent and i know you know what
i'm talking about because i know you've
all seen at some point in your life a
performance like this you know and it
was like time would stop and the dancer
would sort of step through some kind of
portal and he wasn't doing anything
different than he had ever done you know
a thousand nights before but everything
would align and all of a sudden he would
no longer appear to be merely human you
know he would be like lit from within
and lit from below and all like lit up
on fire with divinity and when this
happened back then people knew it for
what it was you know they called it by
its name they would put their hands
together and they would start to chant
allah allah allah god god god that's god
you know
curious historical footnote
when the moors invaded southern spain
they took this
custom with them and the pronunciation
changed over the centuries from allah
allah to oleo leolae which you still
hear in bullfights and in flamenco
dances in spain when a performer has
done something impossible and magic
magnificent bravo
incomprehensible there it is a glimpse
of god
which is great because we need that um
but the tricky bit comes the next
morning right for the dancer himself
when he wakes up and discovers that it's
tuesday at 11 a.m and he's no longer a
glimpse of god um he's just an aging
mortal with really bad knees and you
know maybe he's never going to ascend to
that height again and maybe nobody will
ever chant god's name again as he spins
and what is he then to do with the rest
of his life this is hard this is one of
the most painful reconciliations to make
in a creative life you know but maybe it
doesn't have to be quite so full of
anguish if you never happened to believe
in the first place that the most
extraordinary aspects of your being came
from you but maybe if you just believed
that they were unknown to you you know
from some unimaginable source for some
exquisite portion of your life to be
passed along when you're finished with
somebody else
and
you know if we think about it this way
it starts to change everything
you know this is how i've started to
think and this is certainly how i was
thinking about it in the last few months
you know as um i've been working on the
book that will soon be published as the
dangerously frighteningly
over-anticipated follow-up to my um
freakish success um and and what i have
to sort of keep telling myself when i
get really psyched out about that is um
don't be afraid don't be daunted just do
your job continue to show up for your
piece of it whatever that might be if
your job is to dance do your dance
if the divine cockeyed genius assigned
to your case decides to let some sort of
wonderment be glimpsed for just one
moment through your efforts then olay
and if not
do your dance anyhow
and don't lay to you nonetheless i
believe this and i feel like we must
teach it olay to you nonetheless just
for having the sheer human love and
stubbornness to keep showing up
thank you
[Applause]
thank you
thank
[Applause]
you thank you